i am matt pablosaki and this is donna
magliari and we are
wait for it rx pushers
so this is not going to be a typical
eric meyer style talk
uh when we talk about the dreaded m word
of monads and it's certainly not going
to have any category theory harmed
during this presentation
now the title of this talk is uh curing
your react uh
your uh your event uh processing blues
with
reactive extensions
or
how i learned to stop worrying about
asynchronous programming and love the
observable
so so real time
is everywhere right now and real time
comes in a number of forms for example
on your phone what do you get you get
the gps feeds you get twitter feeds you
get
sms you get everything in fact it's hard
to find an application nowadays that
doesn't have
at least a dozen connections to it
now the data comes in any number of
forms whether it's stocks
rss gps server management
ui events social media
but all of these really are just forms
of databases that we should be able to
query
this for example this mouse right here
is a database
i should be able to write queries over
it even though that the data may not
necessarily be here
but let's take that a step further how
do you start combining things together
how do you really start to reason about
data over time
that's where the essence of the reactive
extensions comes in i want
what's now not what's five minutes ago
i want everything real time and
that's really hard in today's
programming but the intent of the
reactive extensions is to bring them all
together
under one underlying uh interface
or rather set of interfaces and i'll
just
us outright say that asynchronous
programming is annoying
but in order to make our user interfaces
actually responsive we actually have to
pay attention
to this and the problem usually comes
down to is that
every programming language has its own
set of idioms
and uh ways of dealing with asynchronous
and event-based programming
java you'll have one thing scala you'll
have another
in javascript you have promises
callbacks and whatever the node people
want next
and in.net we're just as confused with
tasks and everything else that we have
but each concept
either a promise or an event is really
only part of the story
the promise is only a one-time operation
and the events is a multi-operation
but wouldn't it be great if we could
think about them
both as the same thing
and i think we can through the reactive
extensions
now don is going to actually look uh
start playing with
a few uh applications using the reactive
extensions and this is just some
some small examples of using it
now what we have here is a simple
uh simple mapping of two concepts mouse
movements
and a timer and what we do is we have
some text here called
time flies like an arrow at strange loop
and all we're doing is creating a a loop
for each individual letter and delaying
on each one
in one single query
that all we had to do now if we hadn't
done this
what would we have to do we'd have to
have some weird set timeouts and all
that instead of a nice fluid syntax
the other aspect is game programming
how many concepts are there in game
programming well you need to certainly
have a game loop
you need to uh to have some sort of game
state
that sits around you need to have
collision detection event processing
and everything else and all of those are
either events
or asynchronous operations in one form
or another
so take for example this game of
alphabet invasion
written using rxjs now this has the game
loop written uh
written using a timer loop we react to
events
here and we certainly have collision
detection to tell you when the game is
over
and there you go those are two very very
simple
uses of the reactive extensions
now that we looked at that what do we
usually do
let's take a look at what you usually
see on a daily basis
now this is going to be in c sharp here
but quite honestly the
the the the concepts here uh
apply in just about every language and
you're dealing here with
what's a pool collection or an iterable
you what you try to do is you try to
pull uh an item from the collection
do something with it catch an exception
or re-throw it
and then do some cleanup at the neck uh
on on the finalization
and those uh those concepts there map
directly to
map directly to push-based collections
where we can have on
next for any new items that come through
on air for any optional air handling and
on completed for any cleanup that we do
and what we just saw here was the
iterator pattern
made famous in this book the gang of
four patterns which i'm sure
most people here still have now what we
also found here
is that there are other patterns that
are fairly useful
another one of those being the subject
observer pattern
now the subject observer pattern the way
it it looks in
in in the gang of four book and in most
implementations whether it's
java or ruby etc is that you have the
subject which then controls
all of the observers and has in intimate
knowledge of them
we generalized that pattern just a
little bit
and what we found was that there is
actually a nice deep duality between the
subject observer pattern
which is uh which is push based to the
pool based iterator pattern
how do we actually make it push based
well instead of this having this i
enumerable collection or enumerable
collection as we had
uh previously with uh in our previous
slide
we now have it as an eye observable
collection this could be any number of
things it could be an
event stream it could be loading it from
a from a file could be any number of
things
next what we're going to do is we're
going to create an observer so that's
the uh the
the receiver part of it and we have
three distinct callbacks
on next for when we want to handle
something handle each item in the
collection
next when we want to optionally handle
errors
and finally on completed when we want to
clean up
now how do we actually tie that all
together so
in in the subject observer pattern well
you would have to say subscribe and then
unsubscribe with that same observer
instead what we do
is we actually pass back all the
unsubscription logic
in the subscription itself make it a
first class object so you can pass it
around
from method to method and that's where
composition really comes into play
so what do you do with the subscription
handle once you have it well that's a
good point is
that what we want to do is we want to
get all of the
all the logic together and then at a
certain point we can dispose of it all
at once
so for example you could never have
event uh leaking event handlers
so when you call for example subscribe
with an event handler we add a handler
and then when you call dispose it
removes the event handler
to make that a little bit more powerful
a little bit more complete let's
let's say we want to add three event
handlers together and merge them
together
and we want to add a timer well now
when when you create this subscription
it releases all of those handles all at
once
and not only that cancels the timers and
everything else
that you need to do all at once so there
is no possible chance of leaking
and that's the great thing about the
reactive extensions that really
differentiates it from a lot of other
frp libraries
now because we're asynchronous or or
potentially
asynchronous we need some sort of
grammar to describe what exactly we're
doing
what we have is we have on next which
gives you
0 to 0 to infinite values
so in this case we keep going such as
mouse movements will keep on going going
and going until you
actually stop listening to it
also it's equally valid is that you have
uh
two uh three events and an error
termination
you can also have two slots
and uh two pieces of data and a
completion
but what you can't have happen is
overlapping data
a completion and something that comes
afterwards
because what we have here in this
grammar here is we have on air
or on completed and either of those can
happen but not
but not together and not only that but
this obeys the laws exactly of the
iterator pattern you certainly can't
pull two items at once from an iterator
as you're iterating through
and you certainly can't get a new value
after the
iterator is completed
so in essence what is rx
well besides b being a fairly old
project that started as linked to events
way back during the volta project what
we found is
we found that this was a fairly useful
pattern
that could actually apply across
languages
and what what it consists of is three
distinct parts
the observer and the observable which we
have already seen
query operators which donna will talk
about and the third piece
which i won't call secret sauce is
is the notion of schedulers and the
notion of schedulers is the how
where and when particular things happen
and as i said before it's language
neutral and of course
by that i mean your mileage may vary in
terms of the completeness of of each one
but microsoft or as in we
have released the.net version the
javascript version
which runs pretty much on every single
javascript
runtime whether it's node uh whether
it's
in the browser windows and any other
runtime
we also have c plus plus as well for uh
for those who really like payne
and then we also have uh a java version
from the netflix folks
uh and they're working actively on this
uh
pretty much almost every day uh
releasing new bindings and new operators
and they're also working on clojure
scala and groovy bindings as well so it
really feels natural
and the github guys as well uh worked on
a thing called reactive coco taking a
lot of the concepts
from the reactive extensions and
applying it to objective c
so matt talked about the first component
of rx that was the observer and the
observable
the second component comes from what he
talked about earlier the duality between
the pole base collection and the
push-based collection
so if you think about what you do with a
list in functional programming
there's a set of well-known combinators
essentially
you map you filter you reduce and if you
think about these
most of them don't have anything to do
with the fact that you can get all of
the elements
of the list at once in fact most of
these operators make sense
even if you're getting the data
distributed through time like the mouse
movement
you don't have all the data yet but it's
really just data just like a list
so what we could do with rx is we can
filter a reactive collection we can map
from it
and it becomes very powerful because the
same programming model that you're
already used to
in writing loops over lists also applies
in this new world of asynchronous
potentially asynchronous
push-based collections so
this is all we'll say that's even
slightly category theory related
and that's that the iterable collections
are the dual
of uh observable collections
so on the left here we have the c sharp
name for an iterable which is i
innumerable and what you can do with it
is 4-h over it
you can get the current element you can
move to the next element
you can throw an exception potentially
and there's no explicit completion
because you're done when you're done
iterating through all the elements
with an observable collection in
contrast what you do instead of for each
is you subscribe to it to get the next
element that's your on next callback
there's on error for the exception case
and you have an explicit on completed
because you don't know if there's going
to be more events in the stream because
you're not getting them all at once
so i said you can write really similar
queries in both the poll based world as
the push-based world
so instead of checking my facebook feed
i'm going to check my stock feed for the
facebook ticker symbol
and what i'm going to do here is just
filter that list
pull out the facebook symbol and then
pull out just the
quote values and print them to the
console so a very standard uh
query that you would write over a list
the cool thing about observables is you
write almost the exact same query
but now it's over observables so filter
and map are the same
and instead of for each you do subscribe
and that's what we mean when we say
there's a duality between the two
concepts
now event elements in an
observable collection can be spread out
over time so one way of showing
how these various query operators work
is to use something called a marble
diagram which basically just shows
the ordering of elements relative to
each other
so in this example i'm going to show you
how filter works on the top we have our
our input observable which is our dots
and
the results are on the bottom and here's
a javascript
filter operation on the dots well where
we will
pull out only the orange ones so what
happens is as each element comes in
in the input sequence we apply the
filter and then return an observable at
about the same time as in the input
sequence
so the implementation is a little
different than the options that you
would have with a
with a list for instance because if you
wanted to in a list
you could eagerly look through all the
elements apply the filter
and return a new list whereas with
observables you're actually going to
start
returning an observable at the same rate
as
your initial input of course modulo how
long it takes to run the filter
operation
and map behaves very similarly
so suppose that we want to map circles
to triangles
and again as the input elements come in
the output elements come in and so you
don't need to do crazy stuff to worry
about timers and timing
and things like that it all just
basically works the way you'd expect
now the real power of rx comes in the
fact that
because these elements can be spread out
over time there are operators that
explicitly have a notion of time
one example is delay and we we used this
in that time flies demo where we had
that text that was swirling
throughout the screen so suppose that we
wrote a query
that is meant to delay each element in
the output sequence by
say 100 sorry thousand milliseconds
relative to the input
so basically all the ordering is set for
you and
the output will be delayed and i didn't
have to write a timer
i didn't have to have any callbacks i
just added another method call
and that's really the power of rx
another way of thinking about the
difference between iterables and
observables
is to divide the way you think about
these concepts along two axes
they're synchronous and asynchronous
single value
multiple value so single value
synchronous is pretty much the most
simple thing it's just
a value of type t a synchronous multiple
valued item
is an innumerable or an iterable or
whatever it's called in your language
an asynchronous single value is a task
in c
sharp or a future or promise and
an asynchronous multiple valued object
is an observable
all right so what we can do is we can uh
demo off
uh demo another example of using the
reactive extensions
now one of the canonical examples that
we have
is drag and drop well drag and drop how
do you describe that well you usually
describe it as
as mouse down and mouse move until mouse
up
calculating the deltas all throughout
and as you can see don is actually doing
that right here it's fairly simple to
watch
but what how would you do that in normal
style programming
uh using events well chances are you
would have three separate event handlers
then you'd have some sort of implicit
global state
to care uh to carry over whether the
mouse is down
and the current state of of where the
the image position is so that you can
calculate
and the reactive extensions we can
actually write this as one query
so we'll get the the uh the mouse drag
here
uh just through using a one of our many
bindings that we have
whether you use jquery you use
node you use dojo or just plain old
uh html dom we've got a we've got a
library for that
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take for every ma map down
we're going to use flat map
which basically says we're going to take
a single value and then produce multiple
values
and then what we're going to do here is
start is start by calculating the start
of our particular uh mouse mouse down
next what we're going to do is we're
going to to take the
the mouse movements and we're going to
then map them to calculate the
difference between the
the start and the end position that's
all well and good but how about mouse up
well what we can do is we can just
automatically say dot take until mouse
up
and what that does is that immediately
stops the observable sequence and goes
aha we're done
so what we have here is deterministic
behavior where we're literally saying
mouse down mouse move until mouse up
with fully calculating the entire about
fully calculating everything
now another pattern is to is to combine
it with
unlike concepts so we already talked
about events but what about events and
promises or events and callbacks and you
can certainly do that in the reactive
extensions as well
and remember in every language so let's
let's take for example that i'm going to
do some sort of uh type ahead
kind of example and what we're going to
do is we're going to start typing and
we're going to listen for
an i uh an observable of strings uh
basically listening to the key up
behavior
next what we're going to do is we're
going to query some sort of service
but what we don't want to do is we
certainly don't want to overfl
overload the cloud because while
bandwidth costs money and
and with the cloud it gets even more
expensive even though
prices keep dropping every day but it's
still kind of expensive
and we don't want to introduce any
artificial latency into the application
as well by just overloading the service
so we need some sort of mechanism to do
that
and then what we can do is we can then
take this array
of results and then bind it right back
to the
to the webpage fairly simple code
so we think let's actually see what what
it would be
well we can use our dom bindings uh that
we already have
uh that you can find them out out on
github and uh in
npm bower etc and then we can bind to
the key up
on the input and then what we're going
to do is we're going to map to get the
the the value next what we're going to
do is we're going to have that concern
about overloading the service
now what we want don't want to do is we
don't want to overload the service so we
can have
a throttle where we're basically not
listening we're going to stop
listening as as you're typing
and then when you've paused for for a
half a second we're going to say all
right
we're done and not only that but you
could be
typing using your shift key or arrow
keys
which don't ultimately change the text
at all so we're not actually going to
fire until that's
the text is actually changed
then what we're going to do is uh is
query a service now the search here
is nothing more than a call to a promise
that we can rebind to an observable
so we have a nice kind of back and forth
between promises
but what we need to make sure that we do
is solve one of the hardest problems of
asynchronous programming which is
handle out of order requests i can go
out and uh you see it with your phone
all the time you're like
type type ah come on why did you why did
you pick what i just
uh what i first did not what i last did
how do you how do you fix that on the
reactive extensions we actually
have one single operator to do that and
that's flatmap latest
and what that does is it's a basic flat
map as we saw before with our mouse down
except for the fact that we cancel all
the previous ones and only give you the
last one so all of the
all of that out of error out of band
checking
doesn't need to happen anymore and
finally what we can do is we can just
then
subscribe and bind it directly to the to
the ui
and there you go now
donna will be uh we'll be taking this
example
and and going a little bit further using
the connect
to do some really cool stuff right so
matt showed us how we can look at
things like mouse up and mouse down and
key up events and what i'm going to show
you is what it might look like to get
a richer form of data so let's run this
simple app that doesn't yet have any
functionality in it
and the idea here is that i have a
connect sensor and i have these colored
rectangles
here on the right and i want the user to
be able to pick colors using their hand
so maybe you want to write a painting
app and you want to be able to
to draw with your hands we're not going
to get that complicated here
but that's the basic idea so let's go
over to the code
so in the window loaded event we
basically have
two helper functions uh
above i've subscribed to the um the
color frame which is essentially the
video data that we saw but that's not
really the interesting part
the interesting thing about a connect is
that one of the things that it does for
you
is it figures out where the players are
and turns that into a skeleton which is
basically a location of every joint in
their body
so what we're going to do here first is
get the joints observable right now it's
empty
and what we do is we
set up the events that are coming from
the connect and we turn them
into an observable so just like matt did
with the mouse move and the key up
events turning
those events into an observable we do
the exact same thing
and for instance in the net version of
from event pattern
you provide two lambdas one says how do
you register for events and one's how do
you deregister
and the deregistration is really
important because remember we have that
subscription handle
that later we dispose and what that will
do is it will stop listening to the
event so your app won't do funny things
when you've closed it uh the next thing
that we want to do
is we've no what we have here is
uh right what we have is basically all
the data that's going to come into that
event callback
but we need to turn it into something
that we can write queries on
in particular we could get multiple
skeletons because you could have
multiple users
so we'll just make this a very simple
app and pull out just the first skeleton
the other thing that we have to do is
for each event argument we need to
get the skeleton for that and copy it
into our own data structure
because the kinect is going to give us
new skeletons at a rate of about 30
frames a second
and it wants to be able to overwrite its
buffer so that's what we're doing in the
select statement
uh above where we're saying var
skeletons
equal skeleton frames dot select we're
basically turning this raw event
into the actual data that we're going to
do our queries on
and so now what we end up with with
joints is an
eye observable of joint collection
there we go so now let's go back to our
window loaded event
and here what we remember we get we get
the joint observable and then we call
another helper function
to subscribe to the skeleton now if we
go to this implementation
here we're going to return a disposable
which is going to be that subscription
token
so the first thing that we want to do is
do something different depending on
whether the user is moving their left
hand or their right hand
so for the right hand what we're going
to do is basically move a circle
that represents the user's hand to some
location on the screen
and then we're going to see if they've
put their hand over one of those
rectangles and if so we're going to
change the color of the circle
and for the left hand all we're going to
do is move a circle that corresponds to
that position
and we're going to just color the
outline of that so now if we run this
program
what we'll see is that i can once it
notices me yes there we go
i can pick a new color and the color
changes on my right hand and left hand
just the outline of it changes
all right so so far i haven't really
done anything
that exciting with this i haven't really
written any queries other than select
so let's write something interesting if
you ever if you've ever used to connect
you know that
the way you interact with it is to use
gestures so let's try to detect if the
user is moving their left hand
left or right basically this motion so
let's write a query for that we're going
to define a left wave
as having a negative position of the
left hand versus left elbow
and the right is going to be positive so
basically we create a new observable
that's the difference of the position x
coordinate of the left hand
relative to the left elbow so now we
have
an observable of positive and negative
values then we turn that into
an observable of strings that say either
left or right
and just like matt did with this key up
example we're going to do
distinct until change because like i
said we're getting new data
at a rate of 30 frames a second and it's
going to be kind of useless if we keep
getting a stream that says left
left left left left left instead we want
to see left right
left so let's run this and see if it
works and i'm just going to update a
text box on the screen to show
uh what what my program thinks the user
is doing so we pick a color
that still works and here we go left
right
left right all right
now if you've used the connect you know
that sometimes it can be a little too
eager or some apps can be a little too
eager and you just are stretching on the
couch and then suddenly it starts doing
stuff
so let's make sure the user is really
waving their hands back and forth
so how do we detect that let's say that
if the user is moving
at least three times within the course
of three seconds then it's a wave
so think about how you would write that
ordinarily so you'd have to set up a
timer you'd have to set up a callback
you'd have to align
the timer to the user's motion so if you
start the timer at the wrong time you
might miss
motion in rx it's literally three lines
of code
what we're going to do is buffer the
observable that we have that was the
left right motion
and turn it into a buffer of a time span
of three seconds
with a resolution of half a second
basically it's going to be a moving
buffer and we're going to say if there's
at least three moves
in that buffer then the user is really
waving their hands
and now we're just going to get an
observable that fires true whenever this
hand wave is happening
fine then we then we switch to the
dispatcher thread
because i'm going to update the ui
and i kind of glossed over this before
because we already were on the ui thread
and so it was okay that i was updating
the ui but if you've used any ui
framework ever
you pretty much have to be on the ui
thread in order to
update the ui otherwise you get an
annoying runtime exception
in the case of this particular
observable it actually will switch back
to a background thread
because the timer is going to create
some events on the background
so i need to explicitly make sure i get
back to the user interface thread
before i do any updates and that's one
line of code observe on dispatcher
so everything that comes after that is
going to happen in the context of the ui
threat
so now let's do something once the users
wave back and forth
so i want you to pay attention to this
light here this is part of the demo
this is not an ordinary light bulb it is
a hue
light made by philips and it has a rest
interface
that i'm going to take advantage of here
so what we're going to do here is let's
pick a color so let's go with pink i
like pink
and left right left right wave
and the light changes color and let's go
with
green and again left right left
and wave and now the light's green
so there you have it i did gesture
recognition
i did buffering i did collision
detection
with very rich input data all with only
a few lines of code
all right so what what donna was talking
about was fairly interesting when it
came to
uh to schedule so
really what's what at the heart of it
where
and how does an operation happen
at any point during the uh this uh the
the query we should be able to
parameterize it and say
now we really want to happen here or we
really want to happen say on another
machine
and that's entirely possible using the
reactive extensions
many of our operators as well have
overloads when you can just
shove in a new uh a new scheduler what's
nice so for example
is if i'm doing some ui repainting then
i might switch in javascript to a
request animation
frame scheduler versus say something
that's immediate
especially when you're going to do
something perhaps potentially recursive
now it's it's really what separates us
from
a lot of other frp libraries out there
now when you're writing asynchronous
programming uh
largely you have to think about some
questions how do i run the timers where
do i run them
where do i produce the events how do i
produce the events
and where do and do i need to
synchronize on the ui
well luckily the rx schedulers provide a
single answer
so it introduces the concurrency it's
the heart and soul of how things are
executed
so without them rx largely does nothing
and the operators themselves are
parameterized so that
when during creation and various other
times
such as time you can actually
parameterize that
and what that gives you is testing
benefits
that you'll see in just a second
but what we have is we have many
implementations of the scheduler
and then you have a schedule method that
will asynchronously or synchronously run
your code
with an optional time and neither in in
relative time or in absolute time so for
example i could schedule
something right now for uh for next
year's strange loop
all using a scheduler
now it's now testing is well let's see
asynchronous programming is really hard
in itself but testing it's even worse
so how do we actually fix that well we
have a notion of virtual time
and with virtual time we can actually
fake out what time it
is at any point and so we have a
historical schedule where you can replay
data
but we also have a test scheduler and
that test scheduler then will allow us
to create
observables uh for example here at 300
milliseconds strange 400 milliseconds
loop
and then at 500 milliseconds we're done
then we can run the computation all
together
by just uh running the the computation
which is doing nothing more than
returning the length
of the input and then at the end we can
verify that the results
of at 300 we had a length of seven at
400 we had a length of four
and at 500 we're completed
all very verifiable there is no set
timeouts there's no voodoo there's no
black magic
here this is all just in javascript and
it's all running
synchronous uh synchronously like that
and that's in fact how we've written all
of our tests for all of our frameworks
is using this particular style
so a little bit more about rx one of the
cool things about it is that
last year it was open source by a
subsidiary of microsoft called ms open
tech
and we put out three implementations for
net javascript and c
plus plus and if you haven't heard of ms
opentech they do a lot of really cool
open source stuff like redis and node.js
and openjdk on windows
and in terms of who uses rx well there's
a few people
very prominent people that use it in
production netflix ported it to java as
we said
and they use that in their back end on
their front end they use rxjs
and rx.net github created
reactive coco and uses rx in github for
windows
yep and xamarin is also available and on
soundcloud which is pretty nice
as well so to kind of wrap things up
we have we already covered the uh the
three basic concept of what
rx is so you can find us out on out on
the twitter with uh reactivex we're on
uh
codeplex as well and github and
we take pull requests so please
contribute code contribute samples
contribute documentation
try out rx in your favorite language
tell us your experience tell us what was
awesome what wasn't
and what we can do to improve it and if
you're a fox news
watcher you can send us an e-notes uh
with uh with a particular uh
requesting request requesting right
access because you're a code writer now
what we want to leave you with is just
one thing
if you can take back anything take away
anything from this particular
presentation
is just this the word push
my god that was rad
i think i can do it too push
push push
push push
dude push me do one alone bush
that was good wasn't that good
thank you very much thank you you